Này 1 tâm mẹ hai kể sát băng nhiều sợo sát nhận
đã tầm giıl hai đối tượng liên quan đúng bộ nổ xong sảy ra
tại bãi biển bón tìm, một chứng minh đề điểm công cộng đông người nhất của thành phố sinh đi
theo các nguồn tín bán đầu từ chuyên thông ổ suy lia
vô vương sảy ra trong thời điểm, một sự kiện cộng đông đã được tổ chức với anh in người thông ra
khiến đáp đông bảo trải trong hộ luật, ai sẽ trở biết đã có ý nhất mới người thịt mạng và dương người khác bị thường
và đối tượng mang bố khi đến những trống bị khống trế
đông thời là cửi tế vẫn phó hình cấp để được trịn thải để hỗ trợ các nạn nhăn và hổn định hệ trường
Nhà chức trái cướng cơ gọi người dân tránh xa của bộn đi trong thời gian điều tra
và nâng đề bộ tân công, thủ tương át dư đi, ám anh y spay tạo bán hoàn, chứ sự kiện đau lòng
và người lời trí bộn đi, sẽ đến các nạn nhăn, hông cơ gọi người dân trú của bộn đạn
đường, theo trí gián phụ kinh xát, hiện vụ việc đó hảm dưới liên quan ngày diễn liên,
để các sự kiện cộng cộng cộng đường nữa ở suy lia